ALEXANDER DOROSHKO:
Hi, everyone,
I'm Alexander Doroshko.
I work at Jet Brains and
my primary responsibility
is Dart support
and IntelliJ IDEA,
WebStorm, and all other
ideas that JetBrains ships.
I guess some of you know
me as the guy who answers
in the JetBrains issue tracker.
Catch me during the break.
I've got some secrets for you.
JAIME WREN: My
name is Jaime Wren.
I work on the Google
side on the Dart Plugin.
I try to make sure the
Plugin works with other tools
and things internally
and whatnot.
Alex is first going to
show some IntelliJ features
that all developers should
know using IntelliJ.
And then I'm going to walk
through some Dart and Flutter
and maybe even Angular specific
things in the Dart Plugin
that you should know.
We are super, super lucky to
have Alex here from JetBrains,
and he has worked on the Dart
Plugin for IntelliJ longer
than we have here at Google.
So again for Alex, we're
really lucky to have him.
ALEXANDER DOROSHKO: Thank you.
Using shortcuts, using
keyboard, is more
productive than using mouse.
You'll see the
shortcuts I use right
on the screen for all
operating systems,
thanks to the presentation
assistant plugin.
And I think the first
shortcut to learn
is Command-Shift-A, which stands
for the action, Find Action.
For example, type Dart here.
You will see not only Dart
related, Dart specific actions
like sort members in Dart
file, but also all options
and settings related to
Dart, like show closing
labels in Dart source code.
If you find yourself invoking
some action from time
to time and the action doesn't
have a default shortcut,
go ahead and assign
a custom shortcut.
Well, I know we're all too
lazy to open preferences, open
key mappage, search
for the action,
and assign a shortcut there.
I'll show you a faster way.
Normally we use
Alt-Enter in the editor
to invoke a quick fix
or intentional action,
but it does the trick and the
Find Action pop up as well.
For example, I wanted
to assign a shortcut
to focus the Dart
analysis tool window.
So I find it in the Find Action
popup and press Alt-Enter.
What happened?
This [INAUDIBLE]
is on this bottom.
JAIME WREN: One moment.
This is a live demo.
The only slide that we
had, you have already seen.
ALEXANDER DOROSHKO: I'm sorry.
So I typed Dart analysis
in the Find Action popup
and pressed Alt-Enter.
Did you know that feature?
A bigger challenge is to
find a backhand shortcut.
Like you'll later see, the
shortcut conflicts right here.
And once you have
found a shortcut,
don't try to press
enter or escape.
Probably this is only dialogue
in IntelliJ IDEA that it cannot
close using keyboard.
So I click OK.
And now I can use a
shortcut to open and close
the Dart analysis tool window.
Thank you.
Know that to be able to assign
a shortcut right from the Find
Action popup, you need to
have an editable key map.
So once in your life, you
need to open the key map page
and create an
editable copy Sorry.
This is boring.
I think we need to make this
step not required in future.
Let me find something else
using the Find Action popup.
These days, many developers have
very wide and large monitors
and the default tool window
really doesn't look perfect.
Side tool windows
are limited in height
and the one at the
bottom is too wide.
OK.
Open Find Action
and type widescreen.
From here, you may jump
to the corresponding check
box in preferences or toggle
the option right from here.
You see.
This way is better
for wide screens.
But I personally prefer not
to have two Windows shown
on the screen at all.
So one of my favorites
shortcuts is Command-Shift-F12.
It hides all tool
windows and leaves
you one on one with the editor.
Well, if I need them
back, I press it again.
But I rarely use two windows
for navigation purposes.
To browse through the
project structure,
I prefer using the
navigation bar.
The shortcut is Command-Up.
If the navigation bar is
visible on the screen,
it gets the focus.
If it's not, you get a
lightweight navigation bar
popup.
Here you might browse through
the project structure,
create new folders and
files with commands,
and do whatever you may
need in a project here.
To jump to a different
file, I use Command-Shift-O.
Here you [INAUDIBLE] only for
files, but also for folders.
Or for files located
in a specific folder,
just type any part
of any folder name
and any part of a file name.
To jump to a different
class, I use Command-O. Here,
as well as in all other
places, the search box
understands camel case, snake
case, [INAUDIBLE] matching.
If you remember a
method or a field name,
but not sure where it is
located, use go to symbol,
Command-Alt-O. For
example, if I type main,
I will see all the entry
points in my project,
and as everywhere
else, I don't have
to jump to the source, jump
to the file to see its source.
I can use the action
quick review, Alt-Space.
And see the source right here.
Some people find the search
everywhere action handy,
double shift.
It searches for files, classes,
and symbols, and more in one
shot.
A navigation action
that I heavily used
is Command-Shift-Backspace.
It jumps to the
last edit locations.
We have restarted the ID and
we don't have edit locations.
Well, if we have
Command-Shift-Backspace,
should do the trick.
Sorry.
Next time.
OK.
To navigate within a file,
I use file structure popup,
Command-Shift-F12.
Command F12, sorry.
It shows the same as
the structure tool
window [INAUDIBLE] as
you type, and allows
you to jump to a specific field
or a method or even a test
case, if you're
inside a test file.
More about navigation
within a file.
You know in the top right
corner of the editor,
there is an editor status mark.
Editor status mark.
And there are arrow stripes
on the right gutter.
But to navigate there, you
don't need to use a mouse.
The shortcuts are
F2, and Shift F2.
And one more navigation action.
You see the reference,
the caret is highlighted.
To jump to the next
or previous reference,
first press Command-Shift-F7.
Now this highlighting doesn't
disappear as you move the caret
And now Command-G
and Command-Shift-G
jumps to the next or
previous reference.
OK.
Now a couple of words
about code completion.
What key do you use to select
an item from the code completion
list?
Most people use enter, and in
most cases it works just fine.
You may have trouble if the
caret is inside of a word.
In this case enter
inserts the new item
and leaves old
characters out of there.
If that's not what
you want, use tab.
It replaces the tail
of the identifier.
OK.
What other keys do you know
that can select an item
from the completion list?
Well, space, dot, and comma
do, but effectively, it's
the same as enter followed
by a corresponding character.
I mean an action that
does a bit different job.
It is Command-Shift-Enter,
which stands for the action
complete statement.
The goal of this
action is to try
to make the statement
syntactically complete
and move the caret
to the next line.
It tries to add semicolon,
parenthesis, braces, and more.
For example, in this incomplete
[INAUDIBLE] statement,
complete statement
as [INAUDIBLE]
keyword parentheses
and the semicolon.
And this if statement.
And know that I don't
have to use code
completion, complete statement.
It's also known as smart enter.
It works with the
completion list,
and also you may use
it just in [INAUDIBLE]..
And in this example with, if
statement, complete statement
has a pair of braces and puts
that caret between them again.
How to write the same if
statement using even less
keystrokes.
So-called postfix completion
feature will help.
Well, I still have to
manually type the condition.
But note that I didn't
write if before it.
Instead, I typed dot-if
after it and pressed Tab.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
This is a brand new feature
powered by the Dart SDK 2.0.
There are about 20 ballistics
compilation templates available
for it.
Take a look at them
in preferences.
They're quite handy.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So have you learned
anything new so far?
[LAUGHTER]
Really nothing?
OK.
Thank you.
Now please welcome Jamie
for more cool features.
[APPLAUSE]
JAIME WREN: So yeah.
Yes.
So two things that come to mind.
The Presentation Assistant,
I encourage everyone
to install it for two reasons.
One, kind of funny commands
that are deep down inside
of your menus that
you find yourself
doing over and over again.
Your computer is going to be
telling you what the keyboard
commands are for them to
hopefully encourage you
to use your keyboard instead.
The second reason
you should also go
install the
Presentation Assistant
is not for your own benefit, but
for the benefit of coworkers.
So as you get more
proficient in InteliJ
and you're kind of clicking
around doing keystrokes,
your coworkers aren't
constantly asking,
what did you just press?
And you're like, watch the
keyboard, watch that, right.
So it's called
Presentation Assistant.
Go install it when you get home.
The second thing
that comes to mind,
and it's a real pleasure to have
Alex here because yesterday he
shows the example of--
let me get things set back
up here a little bit--
of you type in Dart
analysis, and then
Alt-Enter to set this up.
And I said, that's great, let
me exit out of this dialogue.
And you cannot hit exit
out of this dialogue,
which I just found just
endlessly entertaining.
So before we continue and talk
about a little bit about Dart
and the Dart editor, we
should talk a little bit
about the Dart analysis server.
What is it?
What does it do?
What have we been talking about
when you've heard the Dart
analysis, the analyzer.
What is this thing?
The first thing to realize
is that it is a feature.
It is a product, shipped
as part of the Dart SDK.
It is a local server which
communicates through JsonPipe
to provide all of
the Dart resolution
for your editor,
IntelliJ in this case.
It provides all of
the code completions,
a lot of the search, the
kind of call hierarchy,
your errors and warnings,
your navigation,
your syntax highlighting.
Everything comes from
the analysis server.
Furthermore, and
this is the future
and you saw a little bit of
it yesterday with the lighting
talk from Mike.
The Dart analysis server also
provides a plugin framework
so that other kind
of frameworks,
think Flutter and
Angular, and packages
can provide their own sets
of information to editors,
their own sets of
errors and warnings,
code completions,
their own navigation, et cetera.
And again, you saw that a
little bit yesterday with Mike.
So let's jump right into it.
This is the Flutter hello world
example that you have all seen,
that you all love.
And the first thing that you
will be doing, may be doing,
is holding down the kind of
command key to navigate around.
Write Command-Click,
you navigate around.
Command-B also just
does the same thing.
All right, Kind of common
stuff you do inside of any IDE.
But you may not need to go
to the declaration, where
some class is declared.
You may need to go
find the usages.
So it's called find usages, and
if can't remember the keyboard
action, you can go
type in find usages.
Alt-F7 on Mac.
Alt-F7 brings up the
same dialogue down here
and breaks it down by the
declaration of the constructor.
It breaks down by
the usages, read
write access, documentation
usages, and all these things.
It'll list them out.
So that's kind of navigating
around, exploring find usages.
The next common way to
kind of learn a code
base, to kind of navigate around
might be the call hierarchy.
So call hierarchy
might be what you want.
So here's a constructor.
We use the same one.
The call hierarchy
is Control-Alt-H.
And again, as Alex
showed a minute ago,
if you can't remember
that, just [INAUDIBLE]..
Open up Control-Command-Shift-A.
And just type in call
hierarchy.
It'll bring you
to the same thing.
And so what this does is
instead of just a list,
this brings a tree that will be
an ever expanding tree of who
does this call, who does
this call, et cetera,
all the way down
to kind of figure
out your path given some
error message or whatnot.
That was navigation, find
usages, call hierarchy.
Type hierarchy.
We have a type
hierarchy, especially
handy with things like
maybe widgets that yo
have been hearing about.
It is not Command-H.
It's Control-H. Otherwise
your windows all
go way and back.
So type hierarchy.
So this is showing my
home page as a state
for widget, as a
widget, all the way up,
so another way to
kind of statically,
without the inspector,
which is runtime.
This is all static
analysis inside the IDE.
All right.
Moving along.
We looked at the Dart
analysis view a moment ago.
Let's get it up
Dart analysis view.
Here we go.
Just a few errors in there.
Let's get some more.
All right.
So I've got some more errors.
Dart analysis view lets
me do things like sort
by the description,
sort by location.
Let me look at things just
in this particular file.
I can also sort by the severity.
I can sort by this file.
I can filter out
things that aren't
in my project in this
directory, whatever you need.
All right.
That's the analysis view.
F2.
So let's say you come
to some new file.
You've got a lot of stuff
in your analysis view.
You want to know if
there's anything in here
as far as errors go.
F2 let's me scroll through,
scroll through the errors.
So I have some.
I'm scrolling through them.
Shift F2 does the opposite.
Very handy.
This icon up here let's me kind
of toggle this and say, only.
Go through errors.
Only go through errors
and warnings, whatever.
OK.
That's the analysis view.
That's the errors
navigation around your Dart,
call hierarchy, type
hierarchy, all very useful.
But the most useful
thing about the talk--
this is the first instance
[INAUDIBLE] is the Alt-Enter.
We already learned
one of the instances.
[INAUDIBLE]
And that is the following.
So with a bunch of errors
and warnings in Dart,
you hit Alt-Enter, and
it suggests things.
So in this case,
it's saying, you
don't have some import to
get the correct resolution.
And here I know that I need
to get material Flutter.
And there we go, and
it's all cleaned up.
So handy dandy.
Alt-Enter on certain
error messages.
Alt-Enter.
OK.
Let me try to get
to my other window.
This is an abbreviated version
of what you saw yesterday
in the Lightning talk.
This is the analysis server.
The analysis server is all Dart.
It's not Flutter, necessarily.
It's not Angular specifically.
But here I've got the
Angular plugin inside,
updated with IntelliJ.
And so I'm going to
get errors and warnings
and hence with my HTML.
And if you saw Lightning talk,
again, you already saw this.
These things are all resolved.
And since I'm in IntelliJ, I
get the value from IntelliJ.
So if I'm editing
some tag, it should
be smart enough to know that
I need to edit both tags.
This is the value you
get from the framework,
from the IntelliJ framework.
And so hopefully the
better editing experience
from IntelliJ, plus things
like the additional errors
and warnings for your
Angular tags and whatnot
should yield a much
happier experience.
And so that's the
Angular plugin.
All right.
I'm going to jump back to
an example you have all
seen many times.
And that is the one right
here, the hot reload.
If you have not seen
it, if you have not
caught it on stage yet, i
will point it out right now.
And that is the following.
Let's get my run dialog up here.
Here we go.
It's running onto my simulator.
I can come down here, and you've
all seen it change red to blue.
Great.
And I can come hit hot reload.
We all love hot reload.
The improvement though,
the last few months,
has been save action.
So hot reload and save.
This helps you from having
to move your mouse down
to a hot reload or
having to decide
between hot reload and a
full reboot of the whole app.
It king of helps keep
you on the rails.
You can imagine
things in the future,
like if we know that
you-- hot reload's
not going to be sufficient
just to do the whole app.
By just doing it on save to
try to keep you on the rails,
keep you from having
moved the cursor
to hot reload, et cetera.
So that's hot reload and save.
I'm going to point out
some other features that
have been added into the
Dart plugin, specifically
for Flutter.
So in Flutter, it's all
about your build method.
It's that structure
of the build.
And so when modifying
or exploring
or reading existing
code, it'd be
really handy to
say, OK, my build
has some widgets that contain
widgets that contain widgets.
Let me go through and
navigate through these.
And so because even
the structure view
comes from the analysis server,
we now have that ability.
So I can come down
here and explore around
the app to say, OK, here we go.
I've got some column and
navigating to source.
So if you navigate
to and from source,
the buttons right
up here selected,
and I select in
source, it's going
to select in the structure
view and vise versa, everything
you'd want to expect.
So that is the build support,
build method support,
inside the structure
view IntelliJ.
All right.
Navigating around the build
method a little bit more.
You may have caught
it this morning.
It's sometimes
kind of confusing.
Where does this curly
brace end for my center
to see what it's wrapped in.
You can kind of have
the highlighting
from IntelliJ here in the
hover kind of at the top there.
We also have the kind of
end of line markers here.
This is not source code,
this center comment here.
That's provided from the
analysis server still
to mark the end of that
constructor invocation,
to indicate that, OK, everything
above this is wrapped,
et cetera.
Now let's say that I know
that everything in my center
constructor, that my
center widget is good.
I need to modify and
tweak stuff around it.
What I really want to is fold
stuff up into that constructor.
And so as of a version or
two ago, you can now do that.
So I can now fold everything
up, wrap it all up,
and now work on the
things around it.
Hover to see what's in it.
It kind of does what you want.
So you kind of navigate
around, edit different parts,
ignore or not ignore
specific parts
as you're working on
your widget structure.
But you're not just
exploring necessarily,
not necessarily tweaking.
Sometimes what you need to
do is wrap a widget inside
of another widget, and the
missing parentheses or bracket
can be a big nuisance.
And so this brings me to the
second instance of the t-shirt
here, which is Alt-Enter.
So Alt-Enter.
I can convert to a child,
move the widget up,
wrap with the new widget.
So in this demo, I'm going to
wrap it with another center
and it's not going to change
on simulator after hot reload.
So let's see it.
Wrap with a center.
Enter.
It put the closing
braces everywhere I need.
It added this, the
hot reload on save.
And it doesn't change
anything, as it shouldn't.
So that's live demo worked.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
One final, One final
little feature.
So we saw a little bit ago
the postfix completions.
This last one that I
want to show is this one.
So S-T. S-T brings up
these three things:
create a new state for widget,
a new widget with an animation
controller, and new
stateless widget.
So you can add
your own settings.
But when creating
widgets and whatnot,
sometimes it's nice to
have some boilerplate,
and you should not be
typing out the boiler plate.
If you have your own
custom boilerplate,
go create your own
one of these things.
So let's just see what
one of them looks like.
So new stateless widget.
It puts the cursor directly
where the class name should be.
DartCon, whatever.
And it brings me
to where it expects
I should be typing again.
So S-T because I can't
remember the rest of them,
some new animation controller.
Right.
And that is everything
that I wanted to show.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]